una nuova terra e sto aspettando me la
gente ma che la legge era tra la gente
la gente invece nostro nell agenda tra
la gente mia dicendo voi questa è
capitato al massimo ma adesso adesso ma
adesso non è che non lo metti sta parte
per questo caso dure ai fumetti perché
chi professionalmente perché siano esse
non averti non lavori più livori più
bella a tutti ragazzi
benvenuti a questo momento io sono con
il mio video gianpi che oggi facciamo
jazz
allora io penso che i giochi che faccio
un po mi aiutino a ripassare tipo
matematica ecco questa geografia per
fisi quello facci paesi
ripassiamo dai solida le cose questa qua
essi va sicuramente voglia di stare in
questo stanno tutti guardando qui
veniamo questo il palazzo dell'unicredit
a milano non so niente dice che potrebbe
muovere 15 diretto possiamo muoverci in
questo periodo la verità non mi fa sta
facendo muovere allora sicuramente
grecia potrebbe essere grecia dai che
non si cresce così prenotate federcaccia
aspetta che la gente no e spartera sulla
costa e giusto a tenere dentro
ora devi aspettare sei secondi a dro era
o non era lontanissima con un tennista
ma era il famosissimo distretto di se
non la potevi tagliare alcuni scorci non
ci posso credere
ma quanta pro vita c'era va bene
dovremmo vedere dalle stoffe insomma di
shine sono statunitensi non siamo in
cina avenue quindi sicuramente new york
su sangio marchigiano in grandi botti
service dell'evento aspetta per lo
guarda york e new york scritto se
fossimo saggio al marchigiano sapremo
meglio possiamo muoverci quindi vediamo
una vita e via
sì però io non abbiamo certo nostro no
no no mamma mia ne ha fatta di strada
che fanno la casa ma non pentagono poi
tutto grosso quindi non importa questo
magari una panineria capito bene è tutto
così va quindi non si fa con i neri a da
ciccio guarda la realtà ci siano ma come
ma come non è possibile
la sperma scusa ai miei 645d chissà
forse ci sono più a san babila
questa la sagrada famiglia spagna si è
sicuro se non è così ti regalo il canale
preferito ma cosa del barcellona che
l'ato e aspetta
però la squadra di qua qua questo è il
mcdonald's eccolo qua 100 per 100 quiz
aspetta la manca al punto il punto
preciso il mcdonald e qua quindi qua dio
2 euro al mese
no 33 metri di sua sorella però 4.989
punti bellissimo così stato bravo una
donna come rifletta del tutto vive stato
sta facendo come se l'italia resta la
posizione quella facciamoci nadai cina
chissà che fai
ho schiacciato come cina cina ma teorico
io sì ma se tranquillo
vediamo per un pugno per ombra per fare
per maturare ho capito la semplicità
chiederà che la cina perché voluto
spiegare così ho copiato la cina era
xi'an
famosissimo sì ma questo video che dura
dieci minuti non 8 milioni tra esercito
di terracotta ho capito ma poi andare
mai in giro così per tutta la cina a
leggere esercito di terracotta bello
questo farace l'uomo invisibile cosa
proc giuro su dio credevi fosse vero no
io questo l'ho visto in giappone che io
questa cosa l'ho fotografici sono però
aspetta fa correre per incredibile qua
giappone ok però ho fatto una fortuna
che ti guarda guarda ogni 1000 nati
nemiche non è lo stesso neve che nella
stessa cosa è la stessa cosa però non
eroi non ero qua ce ne siano di più
perché non ero qua
o magari un artista ma che ne so il
giappone proviamo ero in giappone ma non
sarà mai una serie di tokyo era tokyo ma
non sarà così come un artista che mette
i suoi ragni del in spagna era la stessa
cosa giustamente a bilbao
non sono mai stato a bill trabella viva
va mi piace la parola come il
bagnoschiuma bravo unione europea
vediamo allora deve a me germania
germania gran bretagna vinta la prima si
vedeva tantissimo grandi in terra guarda
le cariche siano tutte cosina in
germania si guarda valente primo piano è
questa c'è il passeggino ma i bambini
io sono fuori serve solo per bellezza ma
presto un villaggio a presto materiale
usato che ci sta di vedetta non vuol
dire non lo sapevo
segue scotch nella nella strada di tipo
no è il gioco della campana a mamma mia
che caso incremento ma il caso assurda
lei ha staccato il pattern che c'era da
lui dal letto davvero pero ma indietro e
quello apposto lo sappiamo da dove sta
andando scusami non so dove
l'inghilterra ne stabilì la faccio finta
prove a testa per questo il prezzo sarà
una camicia nera ma che centro maree un
po più scassati madonna orribile
orribile a brighton della vita filippo
naim con lo sbagliato io come ho fatto
non riconosce il prato che lo
scandagliato parte della casa di felix
non avrei mai azzeccato sui capelli ci
preston e poi preston è molto più onesta
e cuoce presto come l'anno più presto
perché se tu vai a messina c'è anche via
milano capito credo spero dice quindi e
quindi non lo so alcorcon spagna
fortissimo a badajoz
non ho idea di che magari davanti 500
metri perché non abbiamo studiato
però è anche vero ma eccolo nel gorgo
zona industriale
salgono a destra sarà quasi questa
strada qui ma non vedo teca non c'è una
curva forti tipo sarebbe meglio 2019
google però saremo nella nelle curve
al corpo beh beh dai 5 bella noi non li
buttiamo via perché vedi sempre al corso
non è male è quello che ci si è
avvicinati di più in tali veramente si
messina dalla dallara in queste terre è
stata mai visto una macchina di cui
abbiamo perché il postino mi chiedono i
passi quando parliamo schiuma grecia
creta marker e uno non sa dove si trova
lo legge su le città che il medico che
hanno siamo è che per caso se questa non
è scrittura greca noi facciamo una delle
figure più brutti che una volta ho
scambiato regali per ora prix colosseo
dico solo questo io lo faccio però se no
si mi sembra lo stesso tipo di scrittura
se stesso tipo di scrittura dall'acqua
ragazzi sediamoci se noi siamo qui e se
voi siete lì a vedere questo è perché
non abbiamo studiato moltissimo
messaggio da direttoriale non fateli a
tornata la volatilizzazione non c'è
vabbè era giusto però e grecia
missolungi in grecia
mi sorge proprio una cortesia nel senso
e galateo e comunque si era in grecia
però non sa bene però va bene va bene
cielo sono portata di agrigento magari
harris theatre suppongo sia nei paraggi
sky sky the a skydeck è questo il posto
famosi che mask either questo potevano
messi per forza e lo ski vecchio va bene
però dove che ne so jackson jackson
street cioè script non ho la più pallida
idea di dove possa essere farò lo bello
se hi tech crunch iscriverti non
scrivono il new york las vegas dai spara
una città la skin del colonnello che la
posizione dell'utente
no no c'è presente magari tagli stradali
la skin dei cartelli ei take a chicago
chicago chicago pubblica ma chicago una
città a romani
[Musica]